I think the permanence of internet has made people so afraid to be cringy
that everyone is the fucking same
myself include
but like everyone on the internet is always policing everyone else
that makes it so hard to deviate from the very narrow idea of the norm
and like the thing is
let's say someone makes a cringy video on the internet
fine whatever
but that's not the only consequence
you have to worry about someone taking that video
putting it on a different app
having a bunch of people making fun of you
going viral on the other app
maybe it upsets people
then people are messaging your job
telling your school
like literally trying to ruin your life
because they disagreed with you about something that you said
that is insane
like it is insane that we society have gotten that place
like everything has become so palatable
and again I
I know that I've done this myself
like my (PUBLIC) politics in the last few years because my platform has grown
have become so much more like milquetoast
and I've stopped speaking radically because I'm always pissing people off
it gets exhausting
and it's like everyone has become the same
we don't give people the space to like
explore their different opinions or different thoughts
like it was don't give people the space to be wrong
I am a verbal processor
so I come on this app and I just like
I talk that like I
the way that I think through things is by talking them out
so yeah I
I'm wrong often
I will admit but like
y'all make it so difficult to be wrong on the internet
because the second you're wrong
you get crucified